what's up gq this is tracks today we're
going to be breaking down some of the
biggest pieces in post malone's jewelry
collection
so here you have a variety of classic
pieces the first thing that pops out in
this image is this dallas cowboys blue
it looks like a blue sapphire i don't
think it's a blue diamond it looks like
a blue sapphire piece
that i think was a gift that someone
gave him the rep in texas over there
hot boys right with the dripping red and
all of the chains that are around the
neck puffy links
anchor links pointer chains you've got
everything going on over there all
jumbled rockstar meets hip hop
meets down south meets anything you you
can imagine in the world
all on one neck post malone there's a
reason why we're reviewing his jewelry
because he's got a certain style
[Music]
so post malone has a beautiful
collection of jewelry but it's his
watches that make him pop out and stand
out because he's got a lot of value in
those and it's a surprise for a guy with
all the tattoos he's got a collection of
watches
that any businessman around the world
would be envious
of so right here he's got a very rare
very collectible
daytona with a rainbow bezel the rainbow
bezel is sapphires right and i'll show
you an example because i love that bezel
so much
that i make bracelets to match it this
is based upon the rolex bezel
you take sapphires blue green red
pink if you want in a variety of
different formats
the trick to these watches is that you
could take a rose gold daytona that's
plain
and make an aftermarket sapphire bezel
but that's not what postmodern has he
has an original
it is a extremely valuable watch for
instance if he needs to put a down
payment on a house
he could uh send that watch to me and
he'll have that down payment wired
directly to them these rolex watches
take a long time to produce you can't
pump them out like a honda civics
you have to have extremely trained
professionals there's not that many in
the world
and there's more buyers than there are
watches right you could take a trillion
dollars out of the federal reserve
and go to rolex but rolex ain't gonna
make a trillion dollars worth of rainbow
bezel watches it's just not gonna happen
it's physically impossible
that's why these watches are always
sought after i doubt that that trend is
going to change
and when you have these liquid pieces it
turns out to be a serious investment
so again post malone wilds out
completely with one of the most sought
after watchers out there
nautilus factory set diamonds protect
philippe
the difference between diamond district
setters and factory setters for patek
philippe is
patek philippe has to set their diamonds
that they will never
ever fall out that's going to be a
disgrace
for patek philippe if even one diamond
falls out if you have a flashy setting
you know
like you have it in a band or so on and
so forth and you iced it out a diamond
falls out you set it back in
diamond district not the end of the
world however when you're doing
a patek philippe and you have a brand
like that you have to set diamonds deep
you have to hold them in
very very hard and that's what they do
but they've got the baguettes the
emerald cuts in there
set and cut to perfection that is a
timepiece that is
very very sought after it appreciates in
value it's iced it's factory
there's no need for modification and
post malone got it post malone i mean
what am i supposed to say about this guy
he's got the right moves he's got
collectible pieces
that any jeweler dreams about having in
their collection forget about a rapper
again post malone surprises me
with a royal oak offshore stainless
steel
the beautiful dial another collectible
watch it's not super expensive it's
something every day something you could
go take on an airport take a flight but
it is a collectible piece that's always
going to be worth money for him if he
keeps it in mint condition
very goodbye very good piece keep the
box and papers post
malone post also has a large collection
of richard meals that go along with his
pieces now
the thing about richard meals giving him
some of these watches to wear so you can
have this guy
you know as a brand ambassador i could
almost hear
rolex audemars patek philippe really
upset
that richard meal you know in the first
generation is somewhere on that level
and charging as much as he's charging
for
for his watches the richard meal game is
a different game let's put it that way
someone's getting him here they're
selling him there
he's almost creating a currency with it
how long that currency is going to last
i'm not sure but if i had to place my
money i would carefully place it with
audemars patek philippe
and a rolex they've been around for 100
years they'll be around for another
hundred years
[Music]
so here you have a collection of chains
of post malone very iced out
you have an anchor link there with the
baguettes i've seen this in the diamond
district many times
it's not custom made it's something off
the shelf but it's a beautiful chain
right
he's got a pointer a spaghetti with a
square look and then he's got that
solder after anchor link with iced out
pieces at the end
very very nice setup i like it with a
puffy gucci link so it's essentially
he's got every type of link that you can
have except the cuban on there
good diamonds good carrots nothing crazy
over the top you could make that happen
for
30 000 or so for dependence on those
chains
but again he has a certain style it's a
punk style with these pieces that you
would buy at a flea market in stainless
steel except now they're in gold and
they're in diamonds and all in white he
does that white gold look
nothing heavy nothing too crazy but it's
still you know elite hip-hop royalty
style
[Music]
when it comes to this setup it's a nice
classic i style pieces
very unique chains you got the iced out
the devil baby the hot boys
you got a puffy gucci link and some
other links in there that are pretty
cool
when it comes to the chains on this
piece and a setup 100 000 to 200 000
will get you there for what you're
looking at here maybe maybe 250 or
something like that
it's a classic collection of pieces that
i definitely think is fly but you know
if he put his money towards the watches
i don't think he made a mistake
so here you have a classic pave grill
very nice fits his gums very good
you know when you're a guy like him you
got to have a i style grill rose gold
you know it's a nice honeycomb setting
it's not you know the bugettis and all
this other stuff
but it's classic you have to start with
this grill
you can't just start with a baguette
grill and all this other stuff that's
your 10th grill
this is the classic grill for your tops
he's got it
he's rocking it looks good that's it
so here post malone is on stage wearing
a
cross that's not made out of expensive
materials but there's a trend out there
with chrome hearts and things like that
that they're wearing stainless steel
pieces
that's still a couple of thousand
dollars or in the thousands of dollars
it's another look
it's a look to switch it up long chain
with a cross on the end of it the cross
is on the jacket
it's uh more metal with motorcycle more
punk on that tip
you know it's hard to pinpoint the price
because it matters who manufactured that
stainless steel is measured by per ton
when it comes to the price of it now
obviously when you're buying that you're
not valuing
the metal in stainless steel you're
valuing the craftsmanship and the design
and the designer that you're wearing
right you're wearing a cotton shirt
you're not valuing that shirt by what
the cotton is going for
per pound as a commodity you're valuing
it by you know who crafted it and the
designer so that's what's happening here
and it could be in the thousands it
could be ten thousand dollars and
people are wearing these and they're
very sought after
[Music]
so one of the trends that you see in
hip-hop that
is quite interesting it's something not
so aggressive
right let's put it that way you know
hello kitty not the most aggressive you
know it's not a lion head
let's put it that way and you've got a
candy necklace on there but that's a
different look
he has on the one hand the grim reaper
and all this so the bullets and all this
other stuff
you don't need to do that all the time
you have a different side too you show
something a little bit more playful or
more tender or what have you
that's what he's doing over here it's a
completely different look when you're
artist you make different expressions to
the world
and this is one of those for post malone
so post malone's jewelry collection is
pretty dope he didn't throw
vast amounts of capital on his jewelry
collection but some of the timepieces
that he owns
the patek philippe the rare rainbow
rolex audemars what have you
definitely is impressive along with that
dallas piece but that watch collection
is something that is really going to do
them
very very right today tomorrow and in
the years to come so
very important for any rapper or any big
boy thinking about that
everybody grows up kids grow up and you
know at the end of the day
you got to have that collection of those
[Music]
[Applause]
timepieces